[Musique]
ça les gars
voilà et puis alexandre et sera là comme
ça
ce jour là nous avions rendez vous avec
deux personnes nous préparions leur
arrivée car elle souhaitait pour des
raisons que vous comprendrez très vite
être filmés de dos nous tenons à les
remercier d'avoir accepté de nous
apporter leurs témoignages ils choquera
sans aucun doute un certain nombre
d'entre vous bien qu'ils ne soient sans
doute pas unique ce témoignage n'est
sûrement pas monnaie courante non plus
nous nous portons garants de son
authenticité
seront en présence de face alexandre
goetz membres de l'association des
comités de défense des locataires et de
dos nos deux témoins
alors voilà pourquoi faire dès le début
nous étions dans un café rue mouffetard
je ne citerai pas de noms
j'étais en compagnie d'un ami
lorsque plusieurs personnes se sont
disputés plus ou moins
et l'une d'elles est sorti
il en restait encore trois sur ces 3
green qui s'est détaché et nous a dit qu
on est content et tout et tout nous
sommes promoteurs et tout ce monsieur il
est plus ou moins nuisible pour la
société il faudrait si vous pouviez
enfin parce qu'il avait vu qu'on était
plus ou moins d'acquéreurs
si vous pouviez on pourrait le cas c'est
la tête qui s'était en ce monsieur
c'était un c'était un promoteur
immobilier a pointé à pointer wii et qui
les ai payées été payé par la société
pour été payé pour la société de warren
exactement et qui était la personne à
laquelle on voulait casser la tête et
monsieur allait nous étions fait ce
monsieur qui est en face et ce monsieur
on n'a pas dit non tout de suite on a
réfléchi nous avons offert un verre on
vient on va faire un autre et ensuite
je dis bon ben on veut bien mais avec
une petite somme nous a demandé combien
qu'on voulait on lui a demandé un
million
alors il a demandé à réfléchir
mais il avait l'air content tout de même
il a dit on se reverra dans la semaine
vous êtes tous les jours là on me l'a
dit oui
qu'est-ce que vous l'êtes vous qu'est ce
qu'il attendait de vous et il attendait
notons qu'à sa tête à alex justement
mais qu'on laisse qu'un de bien
d'autres deux trois mois d'hôpital
bonne petite volée enfin si tu deviens
coca et puis la lèvre ouverte mais
lendemain s'intéressaient pas parce que
tu as remis les bâtons
oh vous aurez encore regardé il était
très clair il voulait que tu dises pas
une bagarre allemand pendant trois
quatre mois qu'on ne va être plus tu vas
l'hôpital c'est à dire quoi que les
barres de fer
les bras bien bien monsieur
très clair comment trois quatre mois
qu'ils puissent peut
être encline à 30 il pour faire le
il voulait un minimum de trois mois
d'hôpital doit nous dire que
vous l'avez fait alors on n'a pas fait
pour la déraison fait que c'était moi
une chance un ami à nous et on n'avait
pas permis de le faire ça aurait été
quelqu'un d'autre que vous ne
connaissiez pas du tout ça veut dire
quelqu'un d'autre sur le bien je suis
arrivé ça aurait pu arriver peut-être
oui certainement c'était une question à
l'inflexion est ce que vous connaissez
des exemples de gens qui se sentent les
comme ça tabasse et
robin comme on
en a personnellement j'en connais pas
j'en ai entendu parler
il en a qui sait dans toutes les
corporations celle qui se retrouve à
l'hôpital voilà les histoires de pognon
ça ne rate pas dans l'anonymat peut donc
imaginer le métier rentre chez lui ce
coin de tête
s'est dévoyé qui nous attaque
c'est des mecs qui n'a été payée
par une haute borne notre société
pas seulement je connais mais je
tenais pas des gens j'ai pas connu de
gens qui ont fait ça directement mais
j'ai entendu parler que ça ça se faisait
et vous alexandre oui c'est très très
fréquent très fréquents très fréquemment
des nombres de la cdl ailleurs se sont
fait courser des gens
moi même j'étais couchée sur le capot
d'une voiture par des soi-disant
entrepreneurs
du bâtiment
mais je suis personnellement heureux de
pouvoir
apporter la preuve de ce que ce qui se
passe dans le monde d'habitude se passe
maintenant devant les caméras télé ni
cette histoire se passe à paris mais
elle pourrait se passer ailleurs à
marseille comme à lille à lille comme à
bordeaux à bordeaux comme dans bon
nombre d'autres villes de france
le centre des villes se dépeuple entre
1968 et 1975 paris a perdu 11,6 pour
cent de sa population
lyon 13,5 bordeaux 16,3 les banlieues
deviennent gigantesque des milliers de
gens quittent leur logement pour aller
plus loin
qui expulse ce dont pourquoi comment
comment reloger ton ou dans quelles
conditions
comment rénove ton pour qui
à qui profitent les rénovations
rénovation vie ou mort d'un quartier
nous ne prétendons pas répondre à ces
questions mais vous soumettre quelques
images quelques éléments de réflexion
dans les villes de france beaucoup
d'immeubles sont régies par la loi de
1948 les loyers perçus par les
propriétaires de ces immeubles ne
pouvait souvent suffire en assurer
l'entretien et les réparations
temps d'immeubles vétustes et parfois
insalubres
comment en est on arrivé là
on laisse l'immeuble se dégrader pendant
plusieurs années évidemment il faut être
patient mais quand on a une bande
derrière soi on peut être patient est
alors en trois quatre cinq ans comme
dans cet immeuble là l'immeuble est à ce
point dégradée que à ce moment là un
arrêté de péril et pris par
l'administration préfectorale et au nom
de cet arrêté de péril qui normalement
devrait sanctionner le propriétaire de
ne pas avoir fait les travaux
d'entretien et bien on en profite pour
demander l'expulsion du locataire et
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans cet
immeuble ils ont laissé pourrir ligne
même pendant cinq ans après quoi ils ont
eu un arrêté de péril et au nom s'est
arrêtée perrine ils ont demandé
l'expulsion demandée et obtenue
comment notifie ton une expulsion par
voie d'huissier comment s'appelle cette
notification
une sommation de déguerpir oui vous avez
bien entendu le terme juridique et
sommation de déguerpir on les sommets de
déguerpir panneaux s'en allait pas de
partir de déguerpir de [ __ ] le camp
s'il vous permettez cette expression
plus plus saines et un petit peu plus
venir du premier jeu traditionnel alors
ça commence toujours par un lent lent
1975 et le 7 février n'est ce pas les
deux à la fois abonnez-vous à la requête
de alors monsieur machin en l'occurrence
il s'agissait de monsieur le préfet de
paris agissant en ont autant d'arbres
alors j'ai eu huit pieds de daf et
sommation à madame est un occupant de
l'immeuble d'avoir immédiatement et sans
délai les deux acquittés d'une part et
idées notre part de cordes et de bien
n'est ce pas les deux les lieux qu'elle
occupe pour le requérant pour le
requérant en disposer ainsi qu'il
avisera et à satisfaire à toutes les
obligations du sortant et où le sortant
déclarant à la surnommer que faute par l
de satisfaire à la première à la
présente sommation elle y sera
contrainte et forcée les deux à la fois
c'est pas la même chose contre 1 d'une
part france et de l'autre par toutes les
voies de droit tout n'est ce pas cent
ans excepté objets et notamment par son
expulsion et ce nul avec l'assistance de
monsieur le commissaire de police il est
évident que quand une brave dame de 70
ans économiquement faibles reçoit ça et
bien elle a peur c'est fait pour
et elle m'a fait signer le congé de la
alors je dis je peux je ne vois pas pour
lire alors amarré pour d'eau vous n'avez
qu'à signer j'ai lu j'ai signé
sourde est presque totalement aveugle
mal conseillés c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire par une assistante sociale
madame bonnet 72 ans signe en 1973 par
peur de se retrouver à la rue un congé
de l'appartement de trois pièces qu'elle
occupait depuis 1938
[Musique]
elle y vivait seul depuis la mort de son
mari et de son fils son relogement une
pièce de 3 m 68 sur un mètre 96 et une
toute petite cuisine
[Musique]
bonjour comment ça va
ça va ça va
je viens prendre de bonnes nouvelles et
perd du temps oui comment comment va
magazine dans la voisine dans le haut du
panier le seul personnage qui je faisais
mais elle est décédée
[Musique]
quelques fois par an elle gravit cet
escalier pour retrouver telle qu'ils y
ont été mis en pourrait dire jetés
pêle-mêle ses objets ses meubles ses
souvenirs du moins ce qu'il en reste
ceux qui n'ont pas disparu ou qui n'ont
pas faute de place dû être mis au
garde-meuble
trois pièces de leur camp par
l'assistante sociale
kim a déménagé et sous tu as été une
partie de mes choses ne manque et tout
est dans l'état que je ne retrouve plus
rien je ne peux pas y habiter puisqu'il
n'est pas possible de faire de feu ou le
lit prendra feu d'un côté ou de l'autre
vu que la cheminée se trouvent presque
au milieu du lit
et l'a trouvée comme prétexte comme
c'était trop petit de faire si mon lit
en deuil avec à regarder la pastilla
tout a été mis à part si bien que je ne
trouve plus rien
vraiment je serai ce qu'il manque que
lorsque je l'aurais un autre logement
vous pouvez re place et vise à faire
alors là je pourrais dire exactement
tout ce qui manque seulement si tu
risque d'arriver à 72 ans et d'avoir
travaillé pendant 40 encore avoir le
nécessaire pour rien demandé à personne
d'avoir une personne qui soit disant et
délégué social vous faire pour agir de
façon dont il agit c'est inadmissible
[Musique]
en attendant je suis toujours
recueillis par une dame de la rue
quincampoix
qui me loge qui me chauffe kim est clair
[Musique]
mais seulement à 72 ans on aime bien se
retrouver parmi ceux qu'ils affaire on a
passé toute sa bile et heureusement que
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir cette personne
autrement je me trouvais dans la rue
un anniversaire madame donnait
madame monet a été recueillie rue
quincampoix par une de ses voisines
madame josée
[Musique]
je suis revenue au soir à 20h ou tel
camp quoi j'ai pris des déménageurs
parce qu'avec une partie des 2 mais un
père qui était resté là et gérer habiter
ici et c'est là
un jour je suis sorti à 4 heures j'ai
trouvé la porte fracturée on avait mis
un cadenas
c'est un voisin qui m'en vais je suis
allé à la police et oui je suis allé à
la police elle aurait pas dû vous n'avez
qu'à retirer le cadenas alors c'est un
voisin qui me retirer le cadenas et je
suis descendu voir madame josette qui
m'accompagnait là-haut alors livia vite
enlever l'eau le bazar h et
l'électricité tout tout était dans l'air
mais enfin cette nuit là j'ai pu me
coucher et comme j'étais souffrante je
me suis levé tracteur le lendemain je
suis sorti à quatre heures et je suis
allée rue rambuteau fermé commission et
me reposer un peu au square des blancs
manteaux
et c'est en venant du square des blancs
manteaux que l'on commencé à muret ma
porte
qu'est ce que vous êtes en train de
faire là monsieur ici nous faisons faire
je vous laisse y en frais de petits
studios par star est vrai rénové
il y avait des gens qui habitaient là
qui ont ils sont partis ici ici ici
comme jérémy dans cette ville a cité
villa
qu'un oui c'est ça c'est vous qui aviez
et muret la l'appartement de la vieille
dame la grand mère et moi qu'est mort et
là où c'est la 4ème étape
de travaux
qu'elle était sorti rennes depuis jeudi
faubourg et sa porte pour ces
entreprises qui vous a demandé ça oui
ça vous a gêné non moi ça m'a gêné par
une fois interpellé et mehdi peuvent pas
travailler moi c'est juste payer
l'entreprise pas travailler j'ai fait ce
qu'ils ont voulu se servir eux est
d'accord ça va enfin l'agent exemple
criant dépôt at on dit que c'est
dégueulasse mais c'est pas ma faute je
sais pas si j'ai pas été au courant oui
on voulait nous vous la demande et que
vous demandez pas ce que ça mange et le
faire bien sûr je devais après
conditions qu'est ce que ça se passait
pour dédier la semaine c'est pas de ma
faute
bien sûr ça vous arrive souvent ça qu'on
vous demande des choses pareilles
non ici c'était la première fois dans
cet entre puis c'était la première fois
que normalement c'est une piste de
cachettes devise hôtel pourri en valeur
de retape fait de petites tenues
d'accord et tape comme ça ici ses
passions pour des histoires comme ça
j'ai prêté au port et enfin je crois
comportement il est évident j'ai divisé
mais il faut casser la porte il faut
passer tout cas l'avantagé café du
marais elle devait pas être très content
que dembélé mois lors de notre jury
matin quand j'ai rêvé que la petite
famille badinter toi l'héroïne vérifie
c'est ce que j'arrive mbacké dit vous
avez vous été cassé une maison de pour
mr que vient de perdues sur marie ça
fait un an et j'ai perdu un enfant ça
fait 6 noir et donc moi et j'ai dit
weisz coutume amazon c'est pas ma faute
mais je dis que c'est pas à bitar majed
persie nasri s'est passé comme ça
c'est comme ça que je pense et moi je
suis payé pour ça moi j'aime bien ma
fiche de paye à vous de moi j'ai fait
voter quoi quand elle sa porte a été
murée alors là elle est arrivée une
catastrophe elle pleurait tous les
petites de la rue tout le monde disait
mais c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
lui avoir fait sa une grand-mère de cet
âge là
et tout et tout lui et est abîmée
c'était c'était une catastrophe les
cadres de son mari était par terre tout
tout tout était cassé il n'y avait plus
rien de
son lit sa vaisselle avait plus de
déficit et plus d'eau avait plus rien du
tout c'est ça m'arrive à moi
parce que je suis le même le cas en face
chez moi ce sera le même cas parce que
chez nous il ya quatre locataires qui
sont partis et c'est tout cas cessé tout
brisé c'est si ça l'est tout l'autre
fois ils ont fait tomber ce brave block
vous savez depuis la fonte d'un couloir
quand je suis arrivé était à côté de ma
porte je pouvais pas rentrer le propre
et elle a voulu que je suis né me
donnera au troisième en plus petit de
logement veut dire monsieur je suis
mariée ici dans sept logements là et je
veux mourir là dans
qu'est ce que vous espérez maintenant
qu'est ce que vous espérez madame boney
m qu'est ce que vous espérez mal à mener
maintenant parce que j'espère d'abord au
logement crûment et puis
peut-être seule quoi
finir ma vie tout seul
j'espérais gagner ce procès vous espérez
gagner ce procès madame beney
je ne sais pas
on a tellement fait de mal que je ne
sais pas elles seront toutes deux
expulsés de ce logement en mars 1967
êtes occupé de la sphère bonne et enfin
ce qui les conduit d'appeler maintenant
la firme bonnet la sphère de madame
bonnet est ce que c'est un cas d'espèce
oui madame bonnet des mânes abonnés y en
a plein si vous voulez man abonnés
si on s'est intéressé à elle c'est parce
que effectivement il y avait là un côté
spécifiquement ce temps là le mais damon
abonnés c'est à dire des grands mères
qui ont signé leurs projets sans avoir
fait signer y en a plein
rénovation restauration pour qui
alors il ya des problèmes tu voir
différents niveaux il ya d'abord le côté
de l'insalubrité c'est sûr qu'il y avait
des îlots insalubres dans le quartier
qui fallait restaurer encore mon avis
fallait-il le faire à partir des besoins
des gens et non pas d'essayer d'une
manière technocratique
et puis c'est insalubrité la bon dos on
a joué beaucoup là dessus pour spéculer
en disant ce quartier insalubre ce
quartier un patrimoine historique qu'il
faut préserver alors allons-y resteront
mais resteront
la promotion privée a bien senti qu'il y
avait là un bon gâteau eh bien il s'en
est emparé alors même ce qui n'était pas
insalubre même ce qu'ils aient pas
historique il est devenu subitement et
on voit m poutres apparentes pierres
apparentes un peu partout
c'est la restauration n'étant pas bien
sûr pour une certaine classe sociale
c'est clair
les gens les plus pauvres ont enfin du
monde ouvrier des petits artisans
déporté vers la banlieue pour être
remplacés par des
places bourgeoise les classes moyennes
on va arriver dans le quartier un
certain nombre de cadres pourquoi pas et
d'ailleurs c'est paul qui sont tellement
responsable dirais que même sont
victimes ceux qui achètent et qui
viennent là parce qu'ils pensaient
trouver un quartier vivant ils vont
trouver un quartier la mort peut être
pas
transformé sûrement
boutique de vêtements à la mode
restaurant prennent la place de
l'artisanat et du petit commerce
traditionnel
par quel moyen fort ce temps parfois
cette population du quartier à partir
celle qui reste tout au moins ils ont
embauché des mecs moi je suis au courant
ce que j'ai vu moi j'ai entendu je l' ai
vu je vous entends du barétous tous ces
écarts et
des mecs et puis ce n'est que le soir le
vent du soir à lille venait casser les
ampoules nez cassé les cheveux dans les
usa leur sauter puis deschodt études en
poupe c'est ce qu'ils avaient peur le
lieu
de 60 65 ans sont tous seuls
tout ça pour la faire pour les séparer
sans papiers
la propriétaire avait fait dès 8 h alors
ceux qui ont vu son essai intimider qui
ont eu peur de ces gars là qui touche et
en part
par client par ceux qui les suivaient
quoi et bien et puis les locataires
certains ont touché une indemnité notons
pas trop cher maître eminem quoi et
alors on les reloger un peu partout à la
porte d'italie avant ou en banlieue
il ya encore beaucoup de locataires dans
votre escalier avant mince qu'allié dont
je suis seul avec elle seule à résister
qu'est ce que vous appelez les videurs
qu'est ce qu'il faisait exactement
ficher les gens voulaient intimider les
gens parler
qu'est-ce qui leur disait eh ben il leur
disait
on va vous bouclez l'eau les cabinets
les ouates r18 et il le faisait non à
moi ils ont essayé de me boucher les
bois terre mais je connais mes
mouvements
c'est le béton n'avait pas eu le temps
de prendre encore que je suis monté
jacques rue de l'aven c'est le cas il ya
parce qu'ils devaient toucher je crois
on m'a dit tu sais pas si c'est vrai je
voudrais pas l'affirmer m'a dit qu'ils
devaient toucher 2 millions par tête de
pipe maintenant
la dame il se passe un certain nombre de
choses dans votre immeuble quoi
exactement
on dérange tous les locataires par tous
les moyens un tas de petites
tracasseries on coupe l'eau sans
prévenir à chaque instant de jour de
nuit une nuit sans eau 24 heures sans
eau qui fait du bruit
et ça dure depuis longtemps ça dure
depuis longtemps ces problèmes là oui
presque trois ans depuis l'achat
d'immeubles se désole nouvelle
propriétaire oui oui des locataires
voulait acheter leur appartement à oui
presque tout le monde voulait d'acheter
un appartement chacun avait demandé un
crédit à sa banque
et puis mais
on n'a pas pu puisque une nouvelle
propriétaire est venu avec un trop fort
dessous table et vous a proposé la même
chose c'était c'était irréalisable et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le tiers du prix
d'un chat en dessous de table c'est très
difficile à dire mais qu'est ce qu'on
cherche à faire exactement où le déloger
faire part pour faire partir les gens
les dégoûtant de l'appartement faisant
du bruit en ne donnant pas du courrier
en mettant des ordures
tous les restaurants du quartier
apportent leurs ordures ici exemple nous
avons une cave nous sommes les seuls
locataires à avoir conservé la cave mais
on ne la prend pas mais on change la
serrure la carte principale
on avait lu accès
et il y a particulièrement du bruit il
provient de quoi vous pensez que c'est
concernant s'il y avait un gros
ventilateur
d'aération des
cheminées
ça c'est ce qu'on entend alors est ce
que nous entendions
j'ai fait des démarches pour
personnellement pendant peut-être 200
deux heures et demie
dans la chambre des enfants toutes
fenêtres fermées de jour et de nuit ont
une même langue nous entendions du
ventilateur
est impossible de dormir et
les pièces se remplissaient de fumer
avec un ventilateur à main il fallait
ouvrir la fenêtre faire partir les
fumées de la pièce c'était irrespirable
je faisais quelques pas un nuage
et elles provenaient d'où ces fumées
sigi des cheminées mais tout est
fissurée tout est fissurée oui parce que
quelquefois même en pleine nuit ont
donné dix coups de masse dans le mur
pour empêcher le sas et entend le bruit
on entend que tu sois nu sur le palier
toutes fenêtres fermées
[Musique]
et ça a duré combien de temps ça
témoin des mois et et on apprenait
réussi
difficilement
je crois que c'est assez concluant on va
pouvoir arrêter le magnétophone
et alors qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
vous avez entrepris est ce que
maintenant les choses ont changé bien
comme c'est très long les démarches
quand même ma merde on était des gens
comme quand on sort les ordures à 5
heures de matin tous les matins pendant
des mois avec une roue un chariot qui a
une roue un peu aplatie ils n'auront
presque carré alors ça fait un vacarme
sur les pavés et sous le porche alors le
mieux c'est et là on prend d'une
carabine tiré un peu à côté un petit peu
dessus et puis le lendemain
c'est ce que vous avez fait du bruit
toute la nuit bien oui on tire dans la
cage d'escalier et ça résonne et
quand on tire sur tout va bien ça fait
plus de bricoles timbaline des plombs et
vous l'avez vous l'avez fait vous l'avez
fait mais heureusement et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé la police a été prévenue
vous avez ça c'était le jour où on a
entendu pendant deux heures au moins des
coups de masse dans le mur et j'ai
prévenu la police une heure du matin ils
sont venus sont rentrés dans le
restaurant et ils sont repartis ça
continuer vers 2h 2h30 j'ai repris le
téléphone et je leur ai demandé pourquoi
il s'était déplacé il dit c'est une
fuite d'eau qui hument sont là robinet
d'arrêt et je les ai menacé jeudi
écouter où ça s'arrête tout de suite
parce que c'est intenable vous marrez
très peut-être mais moi je descends avec
la carabine que je tire de dents et bien
monsieur cinq minutes après il était là
le brouillard était on n'a plus d'autre
merci mais je crois
je crois que monsieur coma il ya eu un
certain nombre de problèmes vous avez eu
des problèmes aussi dans votre immeuble
qui est tout près d'ici ah oui
absolument beaucoup même qu'est ce qu'on
vous a fait est ce qu'on m'a fait bien
on refait le sortes de brimades oui on a
obstrué les escaliers voix par les
travaux ça beaucoup enfin la république
c'est un passage sur dix ans il vous
reste pas de passage pas qu'il vous
presque parce que pas même les travaux
terminés j'ai demandé quand je me suis
adressée au responsable madame n'était
pas là ce moment là elles étaient tous
en vacances alors cesseront de voeux
monsieur jean je crois tu étais
responsable
à lui envoyer carrément balazé large dit
je vous prends france traite je vais
immédiatement chercher un huissier c'est
ce que j'ai fait et 20 minutes après y
avait 12 6 qui était la vraie gt ou 9
rue boulevard saint-michel et on a fait
le constat lé constat que je vous ai
d'ailleurs je ne peux pas vous énumérer
tous bien sûr vous habitez à quel étage
monsieur tout à fait au sommet au
quatrième et vous avez vous avez quel
âge 91 ans est alors maintenant vous
n'habitez plus dans cette heure cet
immeuble à ces essais est toujours mon
logement et vous ne pouvez pas y monter
assez maintenant
maintenant que j'ai fait faire tout ça
comprenez vous que j'ai cassé les glaces
et
et vous avez cassé glace de quoi et bien
du restaurant
crado que j'étais en boules parce que ce
jour là m'avait fait chinoiseries le
plus alors qu'on m'avait fait sauter la
porte des waters son motif plausible
alors j'ai été le signe de la
propriétaire appropriée at elle dit mais
ce n'est pas nous on n'a pas le temps de
s'occuper de ça enfin voyons voyons
libon moi je trouve la moc huppé malin
il se plaît colère mais monter les
enchères ont mangé un frappe assez
roulant bout de bois oui j'ai physique
du fil de fer puis est descendu les
glaces les glaces de quoi les gars du
reste en mai la devanture de la bulle
trine qui appartient au même
propriétaire qu'elle était apparue un
propriétaire allemand français et alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce
qu'on est bien ma foi j'ai eu trois maps
télescope on a une nuit on a téléphoné à
la police et puis on est venu chercher
un sous-brigadier 80 avaient monté au
panier à salade et puis comment on va
arriver aux commissaires oui voilà
qu'alors en molleton michal à faire un
rapport
pas méchant oui la preuve dans la presse
j'étais rangerait
m bergé l on expulse un certain nombre
de gens beaucoup
est ce qu'il y à une loi pour protéger
les locataires oui monsieur
effectivement là vous êtes surtout dans
le problème de la loi de 48 qui oblige
le propriétaire à reloger le locataire
lorsqu'il veut exercer son droit de
reprise car les locataires ou un droit
qui est le droit au maintien dans les
lieux pour faire échec à ce droit au
maintien dans les lieux il faut que
l'article 18 jours c'est à dire que le
propriétaire propose et donne un local
identique un appartement identique aussi
bien bonne vitrine pour élever
superficie malheureusement c'est parce
qu'ils se passent plus j'ai ouï je sais
effectivement on leur donne quelquefois
des les appartements qui correspondent
pas du tout à ce qu'ils ont quittée
monsieur droz est artisan miroitier un
pari l'immeuble dans lequel il exerce sa
profession a été mise en vente par le
propriétaire les locataires ont proposé
d'acheter leur logement le propriétaire
a préféré le vendre à un promoteur
immobilier
on a dit les gens qui habitent dans cet
immeuble 1 ils sont pas à leur place
ce n'est pas à eux être là à se demander
pour qui sait alors est ce que c'est
vraiment une question de
grosses finances alors si la liberté
dans notre
disons dans notre société libéraliste
avancer cette liberté n'est que pour
ceux qui possèdent beaucoup moi j'avoue
ça me gèle ça me gêne parce que moi je
suis libre de travailler si chez obligé
de partir ou est-ce que je vais aller
les clients ils sont dans mon quartier
ils sont ici je ne suis pas je suis
retire je travaille tout seul je ne peux
pas m'installer non plus en banlieue je
ne pourrais pas et faire les livraisons
et voir les clients et travailler ça
m'est pas possible il faut que ma
clientèle soit autour de moi ce qui est
le cas ici j'ai mis d'ailleurs pas mal
de temps pour rire pour la réaliser mais
maintenant s'il faut que je parte qu'est
ce que je vais faire et pourquoi que je
partirai pour les séries pas ça qui est
quelqu'un qui possède davantage qui au
lieu de québec qui va acheter un des
appartements ou des logements
50 60 80 100 millions 150 millions 180
millions recommandé aux grilles est est
ce que c'est ça alors moi je veux bien
qu'on soit libre que ce soit cette
liberté là que qui va s'installer mais
moi ça me gêne quand même beaucoup nous
sommes dans un système tel que les
promoteurs préfèrent avoir leurs
logements vides mais ne pas baisser
leurs prix il est pressée de cinq mille
à un million à 10000 francs le mètre
carré bien sûr
alors qui peut se payer ça
il est de plus en plus de plus en plus
on verra ses pancartes
que moi je n'avais pas revus depuis mon
enfance et qu'on voit maintenant
couramment dans paris logement à louer
alors ça amène d'abord une désertion
de paris il ya plusieurs centaines de
milliers de parisiens qui ont quitté
déjà paris depuis 1958 et cet exode qui
n'est pas un exode récent d'ailleurs un
quart l'exode de paris ville
on pourrait
remarquer les premières origines au
moment où ce second empire au moment des
destructions haussmannienne et avec la
création de cette banlieue fortement
industrialisés du nord et ce mouvement
n'a fait que s'amplifier sous la
troisième république sous la ivème et
sous la vème république et il
s'amplifiera certainement encore si on y
met si on n'y prend pas garde on va
faire de paris la la ville d'affaires la
city
les promoteurs des loges d'ici reloge
ailleurs des loges ailleurs pour reloger
encore ailleurs et c'est comme ça sans
fin autrement dit si personne
n'intervient ces personnes on prend
conscience de ce phénomène s'est tous
les trois quatre mois cinq mois un an
deux ans et la valise le déménagement
s'en aller ailleurs comme du bétail on
est parqué à droite à gauche dans le
xiiie d'entre elles ont eu ta tion
populations les plus les plus faiblement
constitué
crève et les plus forts lutte et gagne
qu'est ce qui s'est passé madame lebret
le 29 août 72 eh bien j'ai tenté de me
suicider parce que il sait que mulet
d'état de
provocation des démolitions des
écrasements tuyaux gay enfin toute sorte
de chantage mais on veut être dans votre
café qu'est ce qui s'est passé à propos
de votre café très bien ça a commencé en
1971 des travaux ont été mis en route
sans que nous soyons prévenus une
destruction complète de l'immeuble et
nous avons dû subir enfin des
effondrements les clients qui commençait
à s'échapper les écrasements tuyaux les
inondations les chantages les lettres
anonymes vous dit on et ont détruit mais
votre caf est toujours en place eh ben
c'est à dire ça c'est passé juste au
dessus notre notre café au dessus de
notre habitation au dessus de la cour
également
on passe les clients pour aller aux wc
enfin tout notre location a été
perturbé par tout ces effondrements
consécutif mais des effondrements très
grave pourquoi on rénove l'immeuble que
ce qu'on est oui c'est une rénovation
qu'on peut appeler plutôt sauvage une
rénovation
sans
sans autorisation oui mais par exemple
la votre votre plafond au fond semblent
étayées qu'est ce qui suit c'est à dire
que depuis 71 nous étions inondé
continuellement pourquoi parce que les
ouvriers prenaient avec un tuyau
d'arrosage par exemple
arroser leurs chantiers pour faire
partir la poussière et puis tous passés
chez nous on voyait tout se détruire
petit à petit et aucun service ne
faisait cesser ce massacre si bien qu'un
jour nous avons dû être évacuées
le 16 octobre 1973 nous avons été
évacués le château des rentiers ou
l'horloger là et bien c'est à dire que
c'est chez les clochards
oms non c'était pas pour nous reloger
c'était simplement pour nous évacuer
jusqu'à la commission de sécurité mais
on risquait en plus l'expulsion dans
cette commission de sécurité casque est
là qu elle bien la commission de
sécurité a conclu que tout avait été mis
en oeuvre pour nous mais nous détruire
complètement il a même été posé la
question à notre promoteur
est ce que vous voulez conserver vos
locataires oui
évidemment l'architecte a répondu si
vous aviez voulu les faire disparaître
je ne vois pas ce que vous auriez pu
faire de plus madame le bret c'est votre
toit ça c'est le beh
les ouvriers ont enlevé une toiture sont
seulement seignelay la mairie nous ne
savions même pas s'était cachée par un
échafaudage qui couvrait la cour ne
savais même pas comme vous enlevez la
toiture et les pommes mûres de soutien
si bien que en juillet les ouvriers en
juillet 73 des ouvriers ont quitté le
chantier
parce que notre propriétaire promoteurs
les avis pays avec des chèques sans
provision ce qui est d'ailleurs été dit
devant l'expert monsieur
est évidemment de juillet ou septembre
octobre nous étions inondées comme
constamment les pompiers venaient mais
ça se passait toujours le soir et nous
ne montions pas dans le chantier parce
que monsieur le promoteur nous avait
interdit d'y monter à cette époque alors
on ne voyait pas du tout ce qui se
passait et si bien qu'en même temps
elles sont treize comme ça qu'on se
trouvait évacuer un soir avec une grande
grande pluie diluvienne sur paris nous
avons été inondés de tourner au co le
lot des valets dans le café et le
service de sécurité est arrivée on nous
a demandé de partir pour aller près du
château des rentiers mais est-ce que
vous avez averti les autorités de sla aw
oui puisque la police est venue les
pompiers services de sécurité tout le
monde était au courant le lendemain il
ya une commission de sécurité qui a été
ordonnée il a été ordonné de mettre un
parapluie pour couvrir toute la toute
toute la superficie qu'occupaient les
époux le bre un cycle bach mais je vois
que ça n'a jamais été fait depuis nous
sommes toujours sous la pluie vous avait
averti le conseil de paris
je sais que même le maire également rien
n'a été fait monsieur le président de la
république monsieur le maire à sénateurs
enfin le ministre de la justice tout le
monde a été avertie souza répondu
oui et des lettres
très polis si la justice ne veut pas
rendre cette
la loi est bien je ne sais pas jusqu'où
peut-on aller
qu'est ce que vous penseriez fleurs
je ne sais pas mais je pense que il
faudrait peut-être faire très attention
une décision
je pense qu'elle serait assez grave on
peut on ne peut pas le prévoir mais dans
de tels résultats ça les quatre ans
d'attenté trayons quatre ans de misère
qu'attendu de privation de jouissance
commercial pour quatre ans d'humiliation
je pense que c'est déjà suffisant
on est que même en période de guerre
maître rené boyer vous êtes l'avocat de
monsieur madame le bre
depuis que nous avons interviewé madame
lebret il ya quelques jours des choses
se sont passées quoi effectivement le
tribunal de grande instance a rendu son
jugement
et il a prononcé le la résiliation du
bail liant les lebret au propriétaire de
l'immeuble
otor du propriétaire c'est un grand
succès juridiques d'autant qu'il alloue
c'est la conséquence normale de cette
résiliation il alloue une indemnité
d'éviction importante pour les le bret
qui vont enfin connaître la fin d'un
calvaire qui a duré trois ans trois ans
de bataille juridique trois ans de
bataille juridique d'une bataille
juridique très difficile c'est là toute
la difficulté dans ce genre d'affaires
il y a des possibilités juridiques
je précise d'ailleurs tout de suite
uniquement au niveau civil est pas au
niveau pénal et ses deuils et c'est
regrettable
il devrait y avoir une législation
pénale qui interdisent à un propriétaire
de faire sauter le toit d'une maison
défendre et les murs de dévaster un
immeuble pour en chasser les flux les
locataires
il n'y a rien
il a peur d'avoir des connaissances
légal ensuite la peur de prendre un
avocat la peur des procès du oui alors
dans ce cas là il faut leur faire
comprendre qu'ils ont intérêt à se
grouper car le problème est le même au
niveau d'un immeuble c'est une même
action mais à la retraite de plusieurs
personnes alors comme effectivement au
toucher à une classe sociale qui est
quand même pas très fortunés vont pas
dire pas du tout qui pourraient
difficile pour la plupart de l'aide
judiciaire quelquefois ils ont intérêt à
s'unir et à ce moment de demander à ce
que les leur lot le droit soit respecté
en particulier ce faire mes articles 18
et là pour sauvegarder justement ce
problème bien d'autres problèmes
beaucoup de gens signent ce qu'on leur
présente non il faut signer mais non il
faut qu'ils fassent assister dans ces
cas là pour signer on a toujours le
temps quand même de réfléchir il faut
pas qu'on leur extorquent une signature
quelquefois c'est pas toujours le cas je
suis d'accord mais il faut qu'ils
comprennent que ils ont la possibilité
de le faire valoir ce droit qui ne signe
pas le refus d'une indemnité ni le refus
d'un logement car c'est son si
quelquefois le cas qu'ils acceptent mais
dans des conditions identiques
il devrait y avoir une législation
pénale qui interdisent un propriétaire
de faire sauter le toit d'une maison
défendre et les murs de dévaster un
immeuble pour en chasser les coupes les
locataires il n'y a rien
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]